alors bonjour moi je me
je me rappelle partie
herman un matin j'étais dans une auberge
de jeunesse
alogbo
r
sur la vaisselle de mon petit déjeuner
je crois que tu avais chantonnay ou
siffloter 1ère parce qu'un vieux
monsieur s'approcha il avait aussi de la
vaisselle à faire et il m'a regardé et
m'a dit sur le ton de l'interrogation
heureux alors spontanément et semble
véritablement rendre compte de l'impact
qu'aurait mon ma réponse je lui ai dit
vous savez ce matin en me levant j'ai vu
la pluie d'abord je me suis dit bon t'as
le choix heureux ou pas alors j'ai
décidé d'être heureux alors on a ri mais
moi j'avais compris quelque chose
j'avais mis le doigt sur quelque chose
j'avais compris que j'étais le seul
maître de mon bonheur mais aussi que
j'étais le seul maître à bord parce que
moi j'ai grandi j'ai grandi à la
campagne bien à l'écart de toute
agitation
moi j'étais dans mon petit monde moi ce
que j'aimais c'était aller à passer du
temps dehors avec mes potes pour faire
les 400 coups
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas trop l'école j'ai
d'ailleurs vite arrêté l'école je suis
parti il fait un ca fait en boulangerie
à l'âge de 16 ans je me souviens je
faisais 10 km le matin sur mon scooter à
4 heures du matin pour aller travailler
j'ai pris j'ai raté la boulangerie j'ai
fait toute chose les que d'autres
expériences des bonnes des mauvaises et
ce qui est bien c'est que j'avais
découvert le monde du travail
j'avais de quoi je parlais et aussi
j'avais découvert autre chose
l'utilité d'étudier alors j'ai pris mon
courage à deux mains et j'ai repris mes
études
en plus j'avais enfin trouvé quelque
chose qui m'intéressait je voulais faire
du commerce
j'étais passé un bac et puis première
victoire pour moi j'ai été à
l'université chose que j'aurais jamais
cru possible pour moi et puis quelques
années plus tard j'étais manager chef
des ventes
en route pour une belle carrière j'avais
un bon salaire et malgré mon parcours
que certains pourraient dire
d'un petit peu laborieux moi je
l'appellerai le plus atypique
j'étais enfin moi d'y rentrer dans la
norme toujours bien accrocher mes
croyances
j'étais en fait et j'avais passé tout ce
temps en plein dans ma zone de confort
imaginons un peu ce cercle là comme ma
zone de confort comme notre zone de
confort savez la zone de confiance et
pas uniquement chez nous notre canapé ou
jeu notre grand-mère la zone de confort
c'est beaucoup plus pour moi j'ai
découvert que c'était ce que je pensais
mes croyances mes habitudes
mon comportement mes facultés mais aussi
bien plus ma façon de gérer mes émotions
ma vision sur ce monde ma façon de voir
ce monde mes croyances et aussi les
limites que je m'imposais alors j'étais
bien là non mesdames zone de confort est
évidemment j'en ai eu marre
j'avais passé un cap donc j'ai décidé de
partir tout quitter je vais partir en
nouvelle zélande jeu parti seul avec mon
sac à dos j'avais envie de me confronter
à mes peurs et puis de l à la rencontre
de ce moment depuis deux mois même un
petit peu alors arrivé là bas c'était
pas facile tous les jours
tous les matins je reparte à zéro
c'était comme s'ils savaient g2 rendrai
endroit inconnu pour rencontrer des
inconnus
je parle une langue qui au départ
n'était presque inconnu
n'enterrons pas celle tous les jours et
je me rappelle particulièrement le
département premier volontariat alors
pour la petite histoire j'ai beaucoup
fait volontariat les deux organismes
tels que wwoofing work will help ex pour
ceux qui connaissent vous pouvez
simplement aller chez des particuliers
ou même des professionnels travailler
deux trois quatre heures par jour et en
échange vous être nourri logé ce qu'il
soit dit en passant absolument génial
parce que vous pouvez profiter de la
culture et être au plus proche des
locaux alors je me souviens j'étais dans
un plus pour ce premier volontariat et
vous avez peut-être déjà eu la pression
vous faites quelque chose vous savez que
c'est important pour vous que ça a du
sens
j'avais entendu coupe du monde c'est
volontariat mais j'avais peur je me
faisais un sang d'encre dans ce bus mais
c'est mais qu'est ce que je fous là
qu'est-ce que
je ne savais pas à quelle sauce je vais
te manger parce qu en fait j'étais
simplement envoyé à la limite j'étais
sorti de ma zone de confort en fait
j'étais à la limite de la zone de peur
la zone de panique parce que la peur
finalement on ne la connaissons tous
qu'il a paper ici la peur est en nous je
vous rassure un jour où vous n'aurez
plus peur c'est que vous serez mon alors
d'imagés ou là pour 1,1 à un examen
important un entretien d'embauché
un premier rendez vous une préférence
tête dans la peur c'est bien plus qu'un
sentiment c'est aussi un instinct c'est
l'instinct de sauvegarde des espèces je
dirais même à l'époque des loups la peur
c'était notre meilleur d'autres
meilleures inventions elle nous disait
mais mes barre toi quoi ils vont bouffer
fait état aujourd'hui il ya plus de
loups mais la peur elle elle est
toujours là et elle ne joue des tours
plus personne vous mangera tenez j'ai un
exemple les araignées qui a peur des
araignées south est proche bah
qu'est-ce-qui pourquoi vous avez si vous
savez pourquoi vous avez peur des
araignées
pourquoi elles sont dégoûtantes à elles
sont pas belles non les araignées sur la
gâteau plus près bon là j'ai pris une
image une d'araignée de la forêt
amazonienne je voulais avoir un peu plus
d'impact
mais chez nous dans nos contrées les
araignées elles sont utiles elles sont
écologiques pour la plupart elles sont
inoffensives
j'étais plus un botté par des moustiques
des mêmes des mouches que par des
araignées et si on la regarde de plus
près elles sont même fascinante
tout ça pour dire que tout ça ça se
passe dans nos têtes
92 % de nos peurs sont infondées notre
cerveau est d'ailleurs c'est son rôle il
agit comme un trader comme un véritable
scénariste il passe son temps à évaluer
ses seins mais qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer lui faits sont là bas qu'est ce
qui pourrait se passer ça nous permet
d'être prudents et nous sauve la vie
parfois il élabore des scénarios y est
pour faire ça il se base uniquement sur
nos croyances qu'on croit savoir du
moins ce concert où ce qu'on croit
savoir sur le monde et nos expériences
passées
alors moi j'ai une chose à vous tient
mais vous trouvez ça pertinent vous de
flipper de quelque chose qui n'existe
pas en vous fondant sur quelque chose
qui n'existe plus ou qui n'a jamais
existé
tu as peur s'est aussi vue comme une
faiblesse
on vous dit heureuse mauviette et le
courage évidemment comme une vertu mais
je pense que les gens qui ont le plus
peur sont en fait les plus courageux
mandela disait ce n'est pas la piste est
pas le courage n'est pas l'absence de
peur mais bien notre capacité à la
vaincre alors évidemment moi je me suis
confronté durant mon voyage à certaines
de mes peurs peur du changement par
exemple on a tous une résistance au
changement je me rappelle j'avais
déménagé quand j'avais pas une douzaine
d'années c'était l'horreur pour faire 5
km l'horreur pourquoi parce qu'il
fallait que j'adopte un nouveau
changement un chirurgien américain a dit
un jour tu tu as une étude une
cinquantaine d'années il faut 21 jours
pour adopter une nouvelle une nouvelle
image mentale
je m'explique 21 jours pour adopter un
nouveau changement pour s'habituer à
quelque chose de nouveau
évidemment
21 jours c'est court lalime dire mais
depuis peu des d'étudiant à londres et
des universitaires de londres ont sorti
une nouvelle étude des montants
carrément la théorie des matières
j'aurais faudrait bien plus faudra en
fait six mois pour changer d'habitude je
me suis confronté la peur de l'inconnu
on a peur de l'inconnu parce que c'est
ce qu'on ignore j'ai un autre exemple le
racisme le sexisme l'homophobie sont
dictées par les portes de l'inconnu
c'est bien plus un problème
d'incompréhension au d'ignorance carver
est un problème de haine ou autre
la peur du regard des autres c'est alors
la connaît tout ceci depuis notre plus
tendre enfance à l'école même sur les
bancs de l'université on est mis en
compétition faut être meilleur fo qui
est meilleur que moi qui est moins bon
alors moi je me suis dit clamecy tu peux
faire quelque chose est-ce que tu
arrêterait pas te comparer ou même de
juger
est ce que tu pourrais pas plutôt
inspiré parce que finalement en quoi
qu'on fasse et du bon à chacun de nous
il ya du bon chacun de vous ici la peur
du rejet
vous savez quand vous partez tout seul
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
l'ont déjà fait vous êtes tout seul mais
vous avez peur c'est de rester encore
plus seule la peur du rejet c'est en
nous prenons exemple des sdf qu'on
essaie de reprendre un petit peu dans la
société
une bonne douche bonne coupe pour
certains une cure de désintoxication et
un travail et puis ça repart mais non
c'est très compliqué pour eux pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont été rejetées ils sont
eux-mêmes positionner en dehors la
société et pour terminer ma préférée la
peur de l'échec
c'est là dans la société même ici vous
l'avez la peur de l'échec
moi je suis à la base un peu un
perfectionniste prennent qu'il ya c'est
que je préfère ne pas faire que de faire
mal ou de me rater quand on pense comme
ça en fait au final en fait plus rien
l'échec est bien trop mal vu dans nos
sociétés sénèque disait ce n'est pas
parce que les choses sont difficiles que
nous n'osons pas mais parce que nous
n'osons pas qu'elles sont difficiles
alors maintenant qu'on en connaît un
petit peu plus sur la peur c'est
d'ailleurs il a peut-être certains de
vous quittera qui étudie le management
le marketing la communication
la peur est une des émotions principal
de l'espèce humaine
on utilise d'ailleurs comme levier
comportementale par exemple dans les
médias en marketing comme le disait en
communication on vous fait peur pour
vendre des trucs la peur de grossir la
peur de vieillir
la peur de ne pas être à la mode la peur
d'être célibataire alors je me suis posé
la question mais julie kleim est ce que
tu pourrais pas retourner un petit peu
la situation et usées tay peur comme
source de motivation
est ce que vous êtes déjà posé la
question que ferait en l'absence de peur
tu te demandes et la peur elle est
partout un peu plus fun à quoi
ressemblera ma vie nos vies si nos
actions comme étant ivre constamment sa
vie
alors je tiens quand même à préciser
ceci n'est pas une invitation à picoler
c'est juste pour l'exemple
une fois 1 2 verre on est d'accord les
barrières tombent on est beaucoup plus
on dit j'en ai beaucoup plus cool on n'a
plus peur on parle à n'importe qui on
peut parler les inconnus le but c'est de
se mettre dans cette situation parce que
finalement c'est quoi une fois qu'on a
identifié ces peurs ça nous permet déjà
de mieux les comprendre pourquoi j'ai
peur des araignées par exemple une fois
qu'on a identifié l'auteur on peut
trouver des sources de motivation pour
surpasser nos peurs évidemment il nous
faut croire en nous vous êtes les seuls
maîtres à bord n'oubliez pas et puis
c'est là vous la connaissez aussi le
premier pas il faut se lancer
je garantis un saut à l'élastique par
exemple premier par après ça va tout
seul
alors pour ma part un nom nouvelle
zélande
j'ai pu alors je vous passe les mets et
vins non le voyage les rencontres
extraordinaires frais votre expérience
ah non là bas j'étais en fait sorti de
ma zone de confort et j'avais passé de
ces zones de peur et j'étais dans ma
zone d'apprentissage
certains l'apprennent le sapin certains
pour l'appeler la zone magique
la jaune de chance la zone de grandeur
comme vous voulez c'est dans ces zones
au mot personnellement j'ai pu
expérimenter beaucoup de choses des
nouvelles choses comme découvrir le pays
comme j'ai pas mangé des sauterelles
grillées ski et faire du snowboard sur
un volcan en vient presque en éruption
ont des choses comme ça j'ai pu
apprendre aussi une nouvelle langue
d'une nouvelle discipline d'instruments
de musique apprend après de nouveaux
travaux aussi et j'ai aussi vécu
évidemment des échecs des désillusions
c'est la zone d'expérimentation
c'est la zone où les artistes les
entrepreneurs les scientifiques les
sportifs de haut niveau évolue tous ces
gens qui nous inspire encore mieux c'est
la zone des enfants les enfants les
avances sans peur ils essayent il tombe
tu recommences tu seras là il tombe sur
mon site ont jusqu'à jusqu'à y arriver
alors pour parler de la la zone
d'apprentissage
j'aimerais aussi parlé de la chance
parce que pour moi la chance c'est
quelque chose qui ça se provoque
vous vous souvenez cette fameuse après
midi j'étais dans le bus et j'étais
vraiment pas bien je le faisais un sang
d'encre
c'est vrai que j'étais pas au bout de
mes peines une fois arrivé il ya encore
fallu que je marche quelques kilomètres
sous la chaleur et une fois arrivé au
point de rendez-vous le moment crucial
moment de rencontre avec avec mes autres
finalement avec les inconnus que
j'allais rencontrer alors j'arrive au
bord de la baie est parce qu on était au
bord de l'océan et j'ai d'ailleurs eu
peur j'ai d'abord cru à un tsunami s'est
unie à dédier des tsunamis et des
panneaux partout
pourquoi parce qu'elle avait plein de
voitures le long de la route avec une
agitation des gens en dehors des
voitures qu'est ce qui se passe ici
et puis j'ai compris et je les ai vus
les orques dans la baie à 100 150 mètres
en face de moi
une maman en or qu'elle est trop petit
en chasse dans la belle alors coup de
chance coïncidence ce qui est sûr c'est
que la famille chez qui j'étais
qui d'ailleurs s'est avéré être
absolument adorable et chez qui je suis
resté non pas deux semaines mais bien
plus n'avait en quarante ans de vie au
bord de la côte jamais vu d'orques
alors évidemment je me suis pas arrêté
là j'ai continué expérimenté a sorti de
ma zone de confort à me challenge et
puis effet en france mais aussi je suis
reparti
quand on a goûté au voyage et j'ai pu
monter à plus de 6000 mètres d'altitude
le voyage à potosi en bolivie
j'ai aussi fait du volontariat à bogota
et medellin aux orphelinats
j'ai pu me surpasser essayer de nouveau
métier en travaillant comme travailleur
saisonnier sortir de ma zone de confort
mais aussi penser en dehors de la boîte
comme on dit alors je tiens à dire quand
même qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de
voyager pour sortir de la zone de
confort pour le faire ici et maintenant
suivis de trouver quelque chose qui vous
fait peur j'ai pas
parlez à un inconnu pascalou voilà
procès la prochaine session ted certains
centres de confort c'est simplement
s'habituer à faire des choses
inhabituelles et que comme ça qui nous
révèle qui nous arrive des trucs alors
n'attendons pas d'agir pour avoir
confiance en nous parce que ces coûts
c'est agir qui nous donne confiance en
nous alors moi je vous souhaite d'avoir
peur mais vos peurs sera motivante
si vous avez déjà échec des échecs
pardon qu'il soit pour vous revigorant
mais par contre que vous n'ayez pas
l'ombre d'un regret et si vous ne deviez
retenir qu'une chose la peur est une
servante qui aspire à devenir maîtresse
merci
[Musique]
oui